matière d'accueil en matière
d'intégration conformément valeur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre permettait un élu de la
mayenne de vous répercuter les
difficultés de ceux qui sont la force
vive de nos territoires ruraux je veux
parler des agriculteurs qui sont ce
qu'ils sont essentiels pour le maintien
de l'activité pour la préservation de
nos paysages et pour le tissu social et
participe aussi grandement à la qualité
de vie qu'offre notre ruralité
aujourd'hui toutes les exploitations
agricoles notamment les familiales
doivent être soutenus et encouragés
or les agriculteurs n'en peuvent plus
leur travail n'est pas justement
rémunérés trop c'est trop
il doit faire face à des prix trop bas
et ce dans toutes les filières à des
charges trop lourdes à des négociations
tendues et déséquilibré avec la grande
distribution à des retards inacceptables
des aides européennes
que ce soit les dossiers pac 2015
les avances de trésorerie 2016 où les
demandes dette pour les mesures agro
environnementales et climatiques
mais il doit aussi faire face aux
conséquences de l'embargo russe à des
normes et contraintes handicapante a des
inquiétudes légitimes quant aux
conséquences des traités de libre
échange entre le canada et l'union
européenne c'est à notamment pour
l'élevage bovin et porcin est encore à
des suspicions sur le bien-être animal
qui a des impacts sur la consommation de
viande mais les agriculteurs doit aussi
faire face à un sentiment d'abandon
abandon des médias trop parisien qui
répercutent insuffisamment leurs
difficultés mais également les efforts
qu'ils font en matière d'innovation et
d'adaptation notamment en matière
environnementale abandon également du
gouvernement plus préoccupés par les
échéances électorales que par la
situation de l'agriculture qui a
pourtant un vrai potentiel
c'est donc un cri d'alarmé que je vous
lance monsieur le premier ministre la
situation des agriculteurs est
périlleuse et le devoir du gouvernement
est de les aider de les soutenir alors
quelles perspectives d'avenir pouvez
vous apporter à nos agriculteurs et plus
globalement que pouvez vous faire pour
soutenir la ruralité
merci la parole est un monsieur stéphane
le foll ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt le
président monsieur le député vous avez
fait liste de beaucoup de sujets qui
préoccupent les agriculteurs je voulais
revenir sur deux trois points sur lequel
vous insistez d'abord sur la question
des marchés et des prix je vous êtes
fait un constat c'est qu'il ya quelques
années des décisions ont été prises
elles sont légitimes ils ont été prises
par une majorité
la france s'était engagée en particulier
de la suppression des quotas laitiers
voir sucrier
les conséquences ont été assez cumuler
avec des augmentations de production
laitière qui ont entendu à des
déséquilibres de marché très important
je vais me rappeler monsieur le député
et en particulier ça concerne la mayenne
que sur cette question
l'action qui a été conduite par le
gouvernement et par moi-même pour
revenir à une régulation du marché
laitier fait qu'aujourd'hui les prix du
lait remonte on pourrait au moins se
mettent d'accord sur ce sujet est
considéré que le gouvernement a bien été
à l'écouté des agriculteurs sur la
question de la filière porcine après une
crise il y a un an majeur après avoir
tenté d'organiser un marché qu'on
appelle le marché de plérin
nous avons eu affaire à une baisse des
prix qui s'est redressée non pas par
rapport à la question russe mais par
rapport à un marché chinois qui lui même
s'est mis à racheter en particulier de
la viande porcine française
toute l'action que nous avons conduite
en particulier avec le logo viande de
france et l'interprofession de la viande
bovine et de l'ensemble des viandes qui
permet aujourd'hui d'avoir une origine
des viandes qui permet aux consommateurs
de choisir des produits avec l'origine
et la traçabilité que souhaitaient les
agriculteurs c'est un point positif qui
va aussi dans le bon sens
de la même manière toutes les aides que
nous avons mis en place sur à la fois le
pse face à la crise de l'élevage de la
même manière sur le plan de
consolidation
c'est plus de deux milliards deux roues
j'alerte simplement sur une chose
monsieur le député si vous faites plus
de 100 milliards d'économies ne
dépensent plus